derniers préparatifs pour marie-pierre
d'une eau pour les parcours d'ateliers
elle prépare un ensemble de sept off
fait de différentes matières la
plasticienne fait partie des quatorze
artistes yvelinois à ouvrir leurs portes
de leur lieu de création c'est
le moment d'avoir le regard du public
sur ce que l'on fait parce que si on
travaille tout seul dans son atelier
tout le temps
et on donne des choses qui vont être
vues à l'extérieur sont qu'on soit là
bas on sait pas la même chose que
travailler recevoir des gens à découvrir
aussi ses sculptures en stéatite
activités principales de l'artiste
depuis maintenant 10 ans c'est le voyage
dans la pierre j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup
l'élément pierre travailler la pierre
taper faire
de quelque chose de brut en faire
quelque chose de lisse en faire quelque
chose de police quand on travaille en
stéatite
l'artiste accueillera chez elle le temps
de ces parcours la photographe catherine
gendron et son travail autour de sévir